it so happened that during the war on
February 24, the time of the start of the war, we were
part of the national team of ukraine in
spain announced that the
war had begun, russia was selling our cities, and it so
happened that
when we played games that day in the evening
, of course, it was probably the most
difficult game  in our life, then the head
coach of the national team and the world with the rich
offered to go to his native tray, his
city to fish, and there he
agreed
that they showed a lot of credit here with the mayor of the
city of valmiera, we talked about
whether they could provide us with places and
he was briefly told about our museum and
further  our conversation lasted no more than a
minute and he already said let's go look at the
places and I will show you where to take you to the state
and since we are doing this as a
basketball program date through the
basketball community we
have become here to ourselves such an obligatory
obligatory moment to find this
place with accommodation and meals  it
would be the world was the access hall
today we have already taken out 247  man, otherwise we
take out young basketball players or
basketball players of their mothers and siblings,
that is, such a
basketball project, to be honest,
I just can’t believe that it can
be that we met here boards of
such an attitude, such such friendship and
such a desire to help, and even  I couldn't
imagine what it could be